هذا شكل كوني متخصص
يخدم التلوين ويحقق الغرض الرئيسي
ضعف الرؤية ، يعتقد الكثيرون ذلك
هذا هو العامل الذي يميز الطائرات
الجيل الخامس الآخرين لذلك دعونا
اشرح لماذا نحسب حسابًا لا لبس فيه
157 طائرة من الجيل الخامس ولماذا
أيا من الطائرات الأمريكية
يفي بمجموعة كاملة من المعايير في
تختلف عن الجيل الرابع
حوالي 80 بالمائة من دورة الحياة
الطائرات
كيف تلتزم الطائرات المقاتلة مرة أخرى
إنها مناورة صعبة
تاركا وراءه
نعتقد أن طيارينا في 157 يمكن
تذهب إلى أسفل قليلا في وقت لاحق هم
سيفعلون ذلك ، لكن ليس الآن ، عندما يكون لديك
النقل الثقيل
من قريب من الأرض من وقت لآخر
رمي التحديثات انها جدا
لذلك فمن الخطر الغوص تحته
مقاتل يذهب جانبا تواصل
انخفاض
هذا هو المدرج
يبدو أن الماء سيكون في السيارات
الأرض ولكن لا
تحلق في الشريط بأكمله تقريبًا من البداية إلى
على ارتفاع حوالي خمسة أمتار هم
ترتفع مرة أخرى مشهد مذهل
الآن تخيل ذلك على نفس الشيء
سوف يطير ارتفاع سو 57 أسرع من الصوت
[تصفيق]